the nerd is strong in this one
this is Donald Papp and his wife Suzanne
showing off their sci-fi way of
communicating it seems like Donald and
Suzanne have learned to speak droid but
there's actually some clever engineering
going on what's the secret behind this
conversation in order to speak droid
Donald and Suzanne
first of all speak normally into a
helmet and inside the helmet there is a
microphone but unlike a regular
microphone which picks up sound waves as
they travel through the air allow
ringgit bone which is pressed against
their neck picks up the vibrations
directly as it comes out their voice box
this is perfect for these joint helmets
because the microphones are so sensitive
they can speak quietly and not be heard
outside the helmet when Donald speaks
into his helmet his voice is picked up
by his Lou Inga phone converted into an
electrical signal and transmits it
wirelessly to earphones in Suzanne's
mask at the same time that Donald's
voice is being transmitted to Suzanne
another electronic system has detected
that he's speaking and emits droid
speech random beeps and Boop's from the
concealed speakers on the mask the other
great thing about using a luring a phone
is that it doesn't pick up any outside
or background noise this means that the
actual droid noise that the mask is
making isn't transmitted to the other
person's ear yes communication is key
for every marriage well done guys for
taking it to the extreme